The next type of break points I want to
talk about are symbolic break points.
And the use of symbolic break points,
here we go, is eerily similar to how
we created break points in LLDB using
the break point set command and
passing the selector option.
So to add the symbolic breakpoint,
we are now at this menu, and
we need to specify a symbol.
And like we did earlier,
we'll use the selector viewDidLoad.
And after we hit Enter, it really only
appears as if one breakpoint has been
set, but looks can be deceiving.
If we run the application,
as soon as we run, and I'll stop now.
We can see that it expanded out
into all the different cases,
all the different places where
this particular selector matched.
And if we extend the navigator,
we can see some more information
in regards to which particular
viewDidLoad we're talking about.
We'll drag it back and now we'll
check the other options that we have.
And we can see that, besides
the things we've already assumed,
we can specify a particular module.
And so let's add UIKit to
the module field, and hit Enter.
And now we'll run again.
And stop.
You can see that our list
has shrunk to include only
the viewDidLoads matching that
are in the UI kit module.
So with that in mind, let's go ahead and
try another exercise.